un carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
más
no lo sé
bienvenidos a este número especial de
carrusel de las artes desde el castillo
de fontaine blog hoy vamos a dedicar
nuestro programa nuevamente a napoleón
bonaparte a través de dos ciudades
imperiales
[Música]
visitaremos el famoso castillo de font
embl o la residencia de los reyes de
francia que el napoleón se apropió al
proclamarse emperador allí se encuentra
un museo dedicado completamente al
primer imperio
iremos a otra ciudad imperial el mal
mesón para conocer el castillo de la mal
misión un lugar que guarda todavía hoy
un estrecho vínculo con napoleón y su
primera esposa josefina y napoleón
formaron una pareja de leyenda en este
programa les hablaremos de esta relación
mítica con un triste desenlace y del
aporte de josefina a las artes y la moda
[Música]
el castillo de fontainebleau está
íntimamente ligado a los reyes de
francia y a napoleón en el momento de
ser consagrado emperador en 1804
napoleón primero tiene apenas 35 años
decidió entonces convertir a font tembló
en una de sus residencias y así el
palacio en ruinas tras la revolución
francesa se convirtió en un emblema del
imperio tenemos cita para hablar de esto
con el director de las colecciones y el
patrimonio de fontaine blog
[Música]
napoleón descubrió este castillo poco
después de haberse declarado emperador
en 1804 e inmediatamente quedó
impresionado por la belleza del lugar
aunque el castillo estaba en muy mal
estado
napoleón tengo entonces la idea de vivir
aquí en lo que él mismo llamó la casa de
los reyes la casa de los siglos para él
era una manera de inscribir su nombre en
la tradición de los valúa y los borbones
es decir los reyes que vivieron fútbol
15 son su excedencia y ahora bien en
este castillo font o en blog puede se
puede visitar la sala del trono que
tiene símbolos imperiales pero también
de la monarquía efe
en efecto napoleón construyó muy poco en
este castillo está más bien se dedicó a
reordenar y amueblar los interiores y
como usted lo dijo la sala del trono ya
existía desde la época de los ver bones
napoleón sólo la remodeló ahora bien
napoleón tenía una idea muy clara de la
representación de la imagen y de los
símbolos pero apreciaba poco el lujo y
la pompa consideraba que su casa debía
mostrarse
pero también debía ser un lugar de
trabajo así que la sala del trono tuvo
esas dos funciones
napoleón instaló un trono para
representar la dinastía que él fundó e
introdujo dos símbolos particulares el
aguilas recordando el imperio romano y
las abejas que simbolizan el reinado
napoleónico pero los colocó en esta sala
del trono que conservaba aún los
decorados de los reyes anteriores y en
las otras habitaciones del castillo es
de suscripción de pago o fuese no y uno
de los momentos importantes del reinado
de napoleón fue justamente el sin la
aplicación que tuvo lugar aquí en
fontainebleau efectismo univision que
todo aquel defecto de waterloo
efectivamente napoleón a pico en 1814
tras la derrota en la batalla de
waterloo y lo hizo aquí en fontainebleau
en un salón que pasó a la historia como
el salón de la aplicación y que se ha
mantenido casi intacto desde entonces
todavía tenemos los muebles originales
tapizados en rojo y una mesita donde
firmó el acta de la aplicación sabemos
además que antes de firmar napoleón
intentó suicidarse para no vivir esa
humillación aunque luego decidió
aceptar la aplicación definitiva del
final
eeuu 2007 de electricidad
[Música]
en el castillo de fondoempleo se
encuentra este museo dedicado al primer
imperio como una colección excepcional
de objetos de este periodo de 10 años de
reinado de napoleón y en especial un
accesorio característico del primer
emperador francés lo vamos a descubrir
de la mano del conservador general
gestor de leyes
[Música]
y excel
dinámico napoleón habría sido el primer
sorprendido si supiera que su imagen
pasó a la historia como la de un hombre
con un bicornio como emperador napoleón
siempre usó el vestuario característico
de un monarca sin embargo en la vida
cotidiana prefería la simplicidad el
uniforme de coronel de granaderos para
estar en su palacio o de cazador a
caballo cuando debía salir ante sus
soldados
napoleón apreciaba vestirse con un
abrigo simple azul o gris y su sombrero
de dos picos éste bicornio era de
fieltro y napoleón encargaba cuatro de
estos sombreros por año a pupa
el fabricante oficial del emperador
tenemos la suerte en cambio de tener
estas dos piezas originales donadas por
la familia imperial pero hay otros
muchos bicornes en el mundo y no todos
son auténticos surge con diego pto
a la lista mayor y cumplí después de la
caída de napoleón es con esta imagen de
pretty capo al pequeño caporal que los
soldados del ejército imperial lo
recordaron en todo caso los
sobrevivientes fueron ellos quienes
crearon la leyenda napoleónica piense
usted en todos esos veteranos del gran
ejército que quedaron lisiados inválidos
mutilados aquellos que sólo podían
rememorar las anécdotas de esos países
que recorrieron con napoleón se
dedicaron a narrar esas epopeyas así
nació la leyenda de napoleón en la boca
de esos lisiados que realizaron lo que
habían vivido y se ocuparon de difundir
por doquier esas historias la silueta
con el sombrero de dos picos y el abrigo
es posterior a napoleón y suplantó a
aquella imagen de monarca que quiso
construir buena parte para asentar su
dinastía
[Música]
los invito ahora a descubrir el castillo
de la mal misión estamos a 12 km de
parís un lugar que guarda un vínculo muy
estrecho con napoleón pero sobre todo
con su esposa josefina
en este castillo rodeado de vegetación
fue una de las residencias privadas de
la pareja imperial aunque fue también el
escenario de importantes decisiones
políticas
tenemos el agrado de ser recibidos en el
castillo de la maldición por la
directora del lugar elizabeth con boca
lisa beth mugo magiar cavas orina y
muchas gracias por recibirnos aquí
cuéntanos cuál es la historia del
vínculo entre napoleón y este castillo a
la olería out for nature o es un yo se
usa como los defina la relación entre el
castillo y napoleón fue tejida por
josefina ellos se casaron en 1796 tres
años después cuando napoleón dirigía a
la campaña de egipto josefina visitó
este castillo muy cerca de parís se
quedó prendada de él y decidió comprarlo
cuando napoleón regresó a francia se
puso furioso le pareció que era un gasto
excesivo el que había hecho su esposa
sin embargo napoleón terminó apreciando
el lugar mal mesón se convirtió luego en
la propiedad personal de josefina cuando
se pronunció el divorcio en 1809
napoleón fue muy generoso y le regaló no
sólo el castillo sino también el terreno
que comprende un parque de 70 hectáreas
y otras 700 hectáreas de abdomen
también se proyecta en esta residencia
elisabeth que podemos encontrar en esta
casa hay un estilo único de la época del
directorio y del consulado en el que
queda muy clara la influencia de la
antigüedad y del descubrimiento de
herculano y pompeya el castillo tiene
muebles característicos de la época de
napoleón y josefina tenemos también un
museo con obras y objetos del periodo
napoleónico y un cuadro que para
nosotros es un icono de mal mención el
famoso retrato ecuestre de napoleón
cruzando los alpes pintado por la cuidad
y aparte también ustedes presentan acá
un salón del consejo una sala del
consejo me parece que es una pieza que
fue construida específicamente para
napoleón vayamos a verlo
[Música]
y aquí tuvieron lugar 169 reuniones de
napoleón con sus ministros después del
golpe de estado del 18 de brumario
napoleón se convirtió en primer cónsul y
emprendió una tarea faraónica la reforma
administrativa de francia encargó
entonces un lugar de trabajo y los
arquitectos se decidieron crear una
oficina en forma de carpa militar porque
no hay que olvidar que pone aparte es un
general así que estamos en un ambiente
militar las paredes y el techo son de
tela ahí las lanzas cruzadas y en las
puertas vemos pinturas de trofeos de
armas sé que recuerdan a los pueblos
guerreros de la antigüedad
[Música]
y muchas decisiones importantes que
fueron tomadas aquí por ejemplo la firma
en 1800 del tratado de san ildelfonso
que selló un acuerdo secreto entre
francia y españa para la sesión de la
luisiana un territorio que españa había
recuperado en 1763 así que este lugar
fue verdaderamente un cuartel general
para la discusión de temas políticos y
diplomáticos de primer orden pero
también asuntos de política interior así
como la creación de instituciones como
las prefecturas la legión de honor o el
código civil esas decisiones se tomaron
en esta sala del concejo de garzón ex
tramo militar
i
la emperatriz josefina fue una figura
muy importante para napoleón bonaparte y
para la historia del arte algo que nos
cuenta
melissa barranco
josefina de beauharnais primera esposa
de napoleón bonaparte de este matrimonio
civil se guarda el recuerdo de una
tormentosa pasión que comenzó cuando él
tenía 26 años y ella 32 amarillos de
frost es el de la pasión era viuda y con
dos hijos
napoleón la rebautizó josefina para
evitar llamar la voz como lo hicieron
los numerosos amantes que ella
colecciono
oír se ve
así que pensando en la demanda juniors
compasión
más
fueron 13 años de matrimonio con buena
parte comenzados con un intenso amorío
que se desvaneció entre infidelidades al
proclamarse emperador en 1804 napoleón
se permitió coronar el mismo josefina
emperatriz el matrimonio duró apenas
cinco años más y en 1809 la pareja se
separó sin haber tenido descendencia
pero ese corto periodo le permitió a
josefina hacer lo que hoy llamaríamos
una influencer en las artes la moda y la
botánica que no escatima o en gastos en
francia y en cortes europeas su estilo
fue precursor a tal punto que todavía
hoy se les llama vestido imperio a las
prendas con cortes popularizados por
josefina que se ceñían debajo del busto
introdujo numerosas especies florales en
francia y una variedad de cisnes negros
que aún vive en el castillo de mal mismo
donde falleció en 1814
así se termine este carrusel de las
artes especial desde las ciudades
imperiales de fontainebleau israel
magnússon muchísimas gracias por su
sintonía y hasta la próxima
y
lógicamente